the international geneva motor show was
one of the biggest dates on the european
and global car calendar it plays host to
some seven hundred thousand visitors
this year fans can look forward to over
130 new models and concept cars
we were there to cover the highlights
and new developments
volkswagen presents the new terran
while the first generation was based on
the caddies platform this edition is
built around vw's mqb modular
architecture the second generation
terran is lighter but 10 centimeters
longer
the new terran has a completely
different basis from its predecessor
explains volkswagen's group ceo martin
vintercorn but it's still geared to its
customers from families with children to
sports enthusiasts he's confident vw has
hit the bull's eye
the bmw 2-series grand active tour is 21
centimeters longer and five centimeters
taller than its little brother the
regular grand tour
it's also available with all-wheel drive
a third row of seats gives the grand
active tour room for seven
the second row can be slid 13
centimeters back and forth
the new mpv will hit showroom floors in
june
this is more than just a long version of
the active tour says bmw's peter henry
the two may be related but this is an
independent concept with which bmw wants
to reach new target groups
the porsche stand is obviously a
distinctly sporty affair debuting in
geneva is a gt edition of the cayman it
incorporates parts from the 911 gt3 a
283 kilowatt 3.8 liter boxer engine lets
the cayman gt4 post a lap time of 7
minutes and 40 seconds for the legendary
north loop of the nurburgring track
ceo matias mula is proud to present two
very sporty models there's the gt3 rs
and the gt4 the flagship of the cayman
range
the duo further underlined porsche's
performance credentials these are
essentially street legal race cars he
the says smart includes twinamic a dual
clutch transmission making its debut in
geneva
packing a 52 kilowatt three-cylinder
engine it accelerates to 100 kilometers
per hour in 15.1 seconds
top speed is 151
fuel consumption is rated at 4.1 liters
for 100 kilometers
the 4-door 4-4 edition will feature the
new transmission later in the year
449 kilowatts from a v10 mid engine
makes the r8 v10 plus a certified
galloping gas guzzler it takes just 3.2
seconds to reach 100 kilometers per hour
top speed is 330 kilometers per hour the
r8 e-tron can only hit 250 kilometers
per hour but it is after all an
all-electric car a sports car for the
future
ceo rupert stadler calls the performance
sensational 600 or 610 horsepower is
outstanding
zero to 100 and 3.2 seconds is not bad
he reckons
the rh design makes it an ambassador for
the brand it boosts our image and taking
it to the next generation was a good
idea
toyota was in geneva to pull the wraps
off a freshened up version of the
avensis
the family car now comes with a
seriously modified front new safety
features and a new range of engines
it was developed in belgium designed in
france and built in britain
also raring to go a new iris in addition
to the classic combustion engines toyota
also offers an environmentally friendly
plug-in hybrid version the new iris hits
showrooms in the fall
lexus is wowing the crowds with the lfsa
an exciting new ultra compact study
measuring just three meters 45 it looks
custom-made for those congested city
streets but the two plus two cedar has
plenty of space for luxury too it's
unclear whether the lfsa will actually
become a production model
skoda caused something of a commotion
with the third generation superb
boasting luxury features and design plus
slick new colors
the trunk can hold
1276 leaders while neat ideas such as
two umbrellas in the front doors as well
as a lane assist and blind spot detect
system round off the package the new
skoda superb also comes in a four by
four version
seyat presents the leon st cupra great
utility value but also a real racer like
the compact version the st comes with a
choice of engines from 195 to 206
kilowatts
the more powerful version makes the
sprint to 100 kilometers per hour in a
six seconds flat
prices in germany start at 32 and a half
thousand euros
executives fancy an extra luxurious ride
will in future have the option of the
mercedes mybach pullman some six and a
half meters long it cuts a very stately
figure the rear compartment can
accommodate four people who can sit
facing each other
the s-600 pullman has a 50-year-old
heritage explains mercedes hola calenos
a car for heads of state kings and
queens and of course celebrities
6.5 meters long with a wheelbase of 3
meters 70 mean an unrivaled seating
comfort and in the back it's among the
quietest production car rides on the
road
following the atom model named after
opel's founder the carmaker's newest
model bears the name of his oldest son
carl it's smaller than the urban
lifestyle oriented atom but does seat up
to five people starting at nine and a
half thousand euros in germany the carl
is opal's new entry-level model
no carmaker's range seems complete these
days without a compact suv
the cx-3 is mazda's latest contribution
to the segment design and engineering
are as you would expect from mazda fuel
efficient engines will also help to
boost demand for the cx-3 in the
ever-expanding suv market
you